Brian Williams suspended for six months
he's had his problems what our take on
that home purchase which the k2 Brian
Williams listen we all lied abroad right
come on I'm not mad at him for lie and
I'm mad at him for lying in public I was
in Afghanistan I did stand-up for the
troops and I was on a helicopter that
got shot down or was I you're saying to
women you say guys lied away I'm gonna
say that on the nightly news but at a
bar in Hollywood where we're all you
know on ecstasy and scotch a chick looks
like you know with Selena Gomez I made a
helicopter went down sorry I gotta stay
here party your move in is fantastic
yeah yeah
impeccable impeccable my hella honey my
helicopter went down take the cue now
I'm just curious like you now what that
was for the band have you you've you've
lied then you've lied consistently in
relationship constantly I'm the one I
was not one thing I've said here is true
are you know I'm trying to make it you
have you everyone lies it's a human
thing you want to try to get laid you
lie I'll tell you what
hi this is a guy's not this is the God's
honest truth I was I was a club in LA
about 16 years ago I made out with a
chick who I told I wrote Jurassic Park
there's such a that is such a specific
line that is the genius of it well this
was three Google's you couldn't go in
the bathroom just couldn't go in the
bathroom with a stupid Lindsay Lohan
friends I guess that he doesn't look
like him he could have gained weight
well you've got you've got laid being me
remember that okay you are already left
you were to know I always did the show
and the NBC I've been doing the show for
almost 20 years yeah guys part of the
reason I'm in show business which I
don't know if it's a good or a bad thing
with your peers yeah that really
happened you would left so I told I said
I miss India I was I was at about 1999 I
was at a cub game I was doing stand-up
in Chicago's at a cub game at Wrigley
Field there were these ossified drunk
smoking hot chicks in back of me who
thought I was an indie director and I
because they had seen me on Conan they
put two and two together and came up
with five
I've gotten more women saying I'm Andy
Richter and you know I made out I went
back to the chick support when she lived
and I was rolling around on a couch with
her and I got I got a little further
than I can't go here on TV how have you
edited yourself once tonight yes no no
no you're right I you deserve honesty i
alright
well but the problem is Andy at the time
was married well I don't marry at the
time honestly I'm just happy somebody's
getting laid being Andy we gotta go
married and I really uh I really felt
bad because I just got up all she was
sleeping my I I took some Chinese food
out of her fridge and I left that's the
classic but the thing is I never told
her I wasn't Andy Richter right so you
know I said you look at man if your wife
ever heard anything that it was me no
she didn't but now she has question
you